charmel Sheikh on the southern tip of
the Sinai Peninsula in Egypt
residents here are used to hosting
tourists but in a few days time this
city will welcome leaders from all over
the world for the cock-27 United Nations
climate Summit
Simon Steele is the new UN climate Chief
and he knows he's facing problems on
several fronts
we've got a war an energy crisis
inflation a number of countries burning
or considering burning more coal to keep
the lights on this winter is climate
change slipping down the agenda if there
is one defining crisis of our time it is
climate all of the other things interest
rates and cost of living even Wars come
to an end but climate change just
Marches On I don't think there's ever
been a geopolitical
environment as tense and as divisive as
we have now as we enter this cop yes the
world is distracted Shamel Sheikh gives
us an opportunity to refocus
it is a stark warning and a call to
action there are many fault lines to
bridge here over the next few weeks
more than 40 000 people representing
nearly 200 different countries are
coming here to charmel Sheikh and while
it might be under the UN Banner they all
have competing priorities and
motivations and a lot of it boils down
to just one issue money
and as they make final preparations at
the summit venue it's become
particularly about the gap between Rich
Nations who cause the climate crisis and
poor ones who are the most vulnerable to
it
foreign
[Music]
Center protesters gathered to speak up
on just that closely policed but
determined to be heard we are talking
about the climate the changes that
drains the environment in Africa mostly
where the animals are dying so it's
devastating and we need to speak up
about it climate change will affect our
food our water our life our climate it's
so dangerous and so matter for everyone
and everything in this planet
as world leaders prepare to travel to
cop27 there is much to do and much to
overcome
at this African Court expect that issue
of Injustice and inequity to be at the
very center of things developing nations
want to be compensated frankly for the
loss and damage inflicted upon them as a
result of the climate crisis a crisis
that they did very little to cause and
while all of that is going on and there
is a rumbling route about getting loss
and damage on the agenda formerly for
discussion at cop27 there must be
increased efforts to bring down carbon
emissions not promises but actions
delivery mechanisms because the United
Nations is warning that the world is way
off course on that front in fact it's on
track for catastrophic warming it says
if more isn't done